men dating single mothers comes with a
bunch of problems as a sister I would
never want my brother to date a mother
with a child I I really think that once
you have a kid you've kind of made your
bed you should lie in it if you get
lucky and find a husband that's great
but you're kind of done though like
honestly I really don't think you should
make a child with a man and not marry
him and I think you should never leave
if you have a kid with someone but there
is a single mother who recently was
dumped because her child was so poorly
behaved there is a clip going viral on
Instagram of a man dumping a chick for
her son
so why is you breaking up
why okay so so you're gonna break up
with me because of my son
man give me this gun dog what you mean
what you say
I said this one so you gonna break up
with me because of my child he's just a
child he's bad dog she just need a
little guidance man
that's a petty reason to break up
everybody
all these years down the drain
you know what the crazy thing about that
clip
is the kid is actively disrespecting the
stepdad and she's not doing anything
he's swearing at him he's shooting him
with a a Nerf gun and the mother doesn't
do anything but I bet if he disciplined
the child
then World War III would break up
and this is the thing if if single
mothers want to be married they have to
give the stepdad authority to discipline
their kid it's not a fair deal it's
already an unfair deal coming into a
marriage with another man's kid and it
becomes even more unfair when now he
doesn't even have the authority to
discipline the child this is why a lot
of men will pass on single mothers
because they don't want to be
disrespected in their own house and at
the end of the day that child does not
his and now he's dealing with another
man's Mass another man's problem and
maybe that's an insensitive way to talk
about children but I'm sorry that's a
how that's how men see it and this is
just a whole headache that a lot of guys
don't want to sign up for or sign up for
without realizing what they're signing
up for
um and what percent of single mothers
would give full authority to The
Stepfather to discipline their kid would
allow The Stepfather to discipline their
kid even when they disagree with it and
this is why we keep going back to
responsibility the responsibility of
having that child without the authority
over it it's not a fair deal for men
it's the same thing with women having
the responsibility of looking after a
woman but not any authority over her
that it's not it's not a fair deal and
so my question is can we really blame
the men for not wanting to date single
mothers can we really blame the men for
not wanting to date older women and all
the problems that come with it I
personally think no and I think we
should really warn younger women that if
you get pregnant you've really made your
bed and your chance of having a
successful relationship after being a
single mother is low because one men
aren't going to want to date you and
even if they do it comes with these type
of problems that's a more honest message
than the simping and pandering that I
see today that oh men will still date
single mothers you could still get
remarried and all this stuff yes you can
and it can happen but you're really
shooting yourself in the foot and we
need to stop putting single motherhood
on a pedestal we need to stop putting
these women out of pedestal that we
should praise them when single mother
homes contribute to every problem in
society emotional men are a problem it
leads to homeless men it leads to men
with mental disorders it leads to men
that go to prison it leads to men that
commit suicide every problem that you
can look at in society really is linked
to single mother homes it is not linked
to single father homes so the question
is one why do women automatically get
custody and two why are we putting
single motherhood on a pedestal like
this is something that men should sign
up for when it is clear that these are
the issues that kid was not well behaved
and it's clear because he's had a decade
of living with a mother that does not
allow The Stepfather to discipline him
and is not getting proper discipline at
home young boys need discipline from
young men women cannot do it the same
way that men can that's why honestly
guys I think it's quite weird when you
see female bosses like yelling at young
men it's like such a weird dynamic to me
it's a weird dynamic to see like women
having power over men
um I I just think it's weird to look at
and I I think it's an improper Authority
structure but
maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just sexist
maybe I'm just a misogynist I don't know
um
I I think I think it's actually meaner
to tell women that the proper Authority
structures that were equal to men and
have an equal say I think that's mean
because as women we damn near believe
anything you can really our minds are
basically like kid minds and they can
propagate us they can just make us
really believe damn near anything so I
think it's mean to tell women that we
are equal to men because it messes up
the authority structure in the home it
messes up the authority structure at
work and it has us live in this
delusional world where we think we're
equal to men when we are not we do not
bring equal value to the family and we
do not bring equal value to the society
because if we did we could do it on our
own if we were able to do that
if we brought equal value then we could
go off on our own
be single mothers and raise good kids
but that's not what happened if we
brought equal value to society then we
would go off and make these matriarchal
world powers with all of our brain power
because we're such geniuses
but we're not and that's the thing like
they have just told us that we're Queens
for so long they've told us they've even
brainwashed Us in the church telling us
oh we need to equally submit to our
husband guys we have to start calling
this out anything that implies
we're equal is evil and it is
brainwashing and it is meant to break
down the family and break down Society
but guys maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just
talking these conspiracy theories just
acting wild you know being this just
crazy chick you know maybe women should
overpower men maybe women are the queens
and the prize let me know in the
comments what you guys think like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time